if you're a girl do you reckon you do
only fans because i spend
far more time than you'd expect thinking
about whether or not i'd do only funds
if i was a girl really well you can as a
guy right
but there's like a way only there's the
guy waiting right it's yeah there is
there's a gender wage gap
it's terrifying yeah do you know what
else there is that i've been talking
with us on stage but there's a
there's a red hair wage gap i don't know
if you know that where people would
rather
make less money they make less money and
some people think it's because of the
jobs they take like there's less money
in being a carnival operator or a
backyard wrestler or uh biting the heads
off chickens
but um i thought
i thought that i thought you meant that
they made specifically less on only fans
like people were like i don't want to
see that ginger
pubic hair but i identify as part of the
community i have a few reds in my beard
yeah but you probably too me too yeah
exactly we're a very very ostracized
people
uh i don't know if i would to be honest
i mean
it's hard to i i think i always have
this conversa it's always funny to like
that conversation like if i was a girl
and people always say this with races
right they're like if you were a black
guy like would you think like this and
i'm like well am i still
me or am i different guy like because if
i'm still me
like i have a pretty contrarian like
personality like my guess would be that
i would find myself like in whatever
counter culture
you know surrounded me then but if like
if you're like well you're
you have a different brain well then
you're like well yeah then yeah i'd be
different in that scenario if i'm a
different guy
but with the girl if i if i'm me
i think that i'd be you know probably
doing some version of
comedy or you know something like that
as a girl but if i'm like some
yeah so it's hard to say because if if
i'm me still probably not but
what's the is there a difference in male
comics and female comics
in terms of what they got i mean why
don't you get into your opinions on that
no i mean is there a difference in terms
of how much they get paid
yeah yeah there's guy comedy and then we
go okay guys uh i hope you had fun with
that person now we're gonna do the uh
there's some girl comedy boys in the
show
i didn't know i didn't know that it was
that bad i mean when you think about the
netflix specials and stuff
not a massive amount of women on there
i think that um i think that uh
there is like a difference in
if you're masculine versus feminine like
how you do well but it's the same thing
in real life you know what i mean
if uh i mean there's you're commanding a
room full of people you know what i mean
so it kind of is just like a masculine
art form to begin with
and people are comfortable hearing a
woman
talk about different things than a man
and there's there's
there's like here's a perfect example
like if you were
at like a bar or something like that and
some girl comes up to you and kind of
like makes fun of you you might
not feel something about that right but
if a guy came up to you and he kind of
like tried to
come out of nowhere and take a dig at
your personality or something in front
of your chick you're like
yo what the like so there's just
different you know the girl a girl could
come steal your hat at a bar and it's
not gonna be a fight whereas a guy can
right but then there's
vice versa with that right so on stage
it's the same thing like everyone
is willing to like take take different
uh you know you're allowed to kind of do
different things based on like the
culture of
people there on dates right so if you're
a girl you want to make sure that girl
doesn't think you're like trying to
steal her dude and there's
if you're a guy the same thing right so
there's like just these all these like
dynamics that are no different than real
life
demisexual that's the solution everybody
stay demisexual
and then you're all safe from it it
literally
solves all problems and it solves the
problems of
if every girl is in like the victim
class then you know you
kind of you know don't really have to
hear it about it anymore it's just
everyone that's true i had this quote uh
carl benjamin guy from over here said
in the same way that constant access to
porn is deforming men's expectations of
women
only fans is deforming women's
expectations of men that was something
i'd never really thought about the fact
that
the way that the girls that perhaps do
only fans or maybe have a friend that
does only fans or
even a friend that i don't know is on
the outside you know they just do foot
stuff maybe or i don't know something
else yeah
what that means for sort of the
relationship between a girl and a guy
now like what do they expect from each
other i think that was quite interesting
there's there's kind of i always like
think that
the one of the biggest problems with um
everything right now and like the
biggest like disconnect in the
conversation
is that people want to like normalize
things that are sort of like cowboy
lifestyles
and like for me like i've sort of lived
a cowboy lifestyle like i was you know
i've been like a
comic and been on the you know lived on
tour to
200 you know days a year and never had a
normal job and then scraped by doing
this and then was kind of
like i've just lived this like super
alternative lifestyle my entire life
right
and even when it comes to like
relationships and a lot of times stuff
like that
but it's like a hard thing to do and it
takes like a specific type of person and
it also takes
you know kind of a lot of uh trying to
i don't know if like mental resilience
but you need to like focus on
you know not being a mess because
otherwise you just end up like a
depressed alcoholic or some [ __ ] right
so i think that if you're a certain type
of person
none of this matters but the truth is
like yeah if you're like a
certain type of you know let's say a
weaker person you go yeah you
probably can't handle that lifestyle but
some people can so that's
it all depends on like who you are you
know what i mean i don't think it's as
simple as
it is or isn't good it's like yo are you
the type of person that can handle this
[ __ ]
and then if when they're not they do it
and then they go society needs to like
change to make
this easier and you go nah you weren't
suited for that thing
that's what i think like kind of a lot
of this stuff uh
revolves around but the same way if
you're a dude that's like
out there smashing like if you're some
20 year old that's just like running
through chicks
or you're like let's say a hockey like a
like a you know professional football
player or something you know what i mean
or whatever in a famous rapper or
something right
those guys it's the same sort of thing
like you when you when women are that
disposable like it does make you uh
think of girls as like look at it like
they're nothing you know what i mean
and they're all schemey like they're all
up to something you don't trust them and
it's
a because the type of girls you're
around and how they are around you
and be like you just see like the worst
side of them i think i can't remember
who the rapper
probably but a rapper came to newcastle
and
had sent one of his assistants out into
the crowd
and uh wanted to sleep with a redhead
that night
so his assistant yeah and a couple of
her friends had gone out into the crowd
on like redhead watch
and they'd gone and spoken to four or
five different redheads that were in the
crowd that they thought
like yeah like the rod stewart style
yeah it could be suitable candidates
like tonight i fancy
someone lithuanian let's find someone
lithuanian in the crowd
yeah it turns you into this psychopath
[ __ ] mental
i couldn't believe that apparently this
girl had turned up and in the tour bus
there was her
and four of the redheads yeah and then
the
rapper is like hmm after much
deliberation
i decided to go with fat white chick
again
for the ninth night in a row sire
with the plebs they are not up to
standard tonight
yeah exactly so yeah i guess like
being that guy probably you know makes
you think that they're especially after
some chick that's
online still on your feet and you have
about 9 000 dudes like simping like
but if i give you an extra 20 bucks can
you say yeah it's like you're like yo
dudes are
losers but difficult to hold on to that
man but i think um
it's interesting about having
the drugs and the sex but none of the
rock and roll
as a part of that like you can live the
lifestyle yeah
you can live the lifestyle of someone
that's this sort of traveling
itinerant that's good yeah no [ __ ]
girls always good like there's no dude
that's living the lifestyle of a
billionaire without being a billionaire
guess what there are a million girls
that are out there living like they're a
billionaire right now
so this ain't a new thing that like
girls can [ __ ]
you know live like that even without
doing the thing that's
you know what a group he was whatever
but this
you know me yeah they don't even have to
be like odd now
dude there's jinx at like sixes and
they're like yo top one percent of only
fans you're like
[Laughter]
if you've got in your bio london miami
dubai
and no verifiable source of income
that's what's happening guys are funny
yeah i i agree those guys are so funny
with all that
like you live in every city i know i
know some specific dudes like that they
are
like live in every city and you're like
you're on a couch
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace
you